traffic jam is a common problem for big
cities not only in Brazil but in the
world people get stuck in traffic jam
all the time and they lose a lot of time
we have economic losses and pollution
tackling this problem is a challenge
devil travaglio elaborado Bell
Association national transport public
key most rocky new energy new mop
centers in La Venta wait for no gastos
safe kg Vince toys million see me get at
a disco dance a condo media regional
stainless crash come into their new tres
veces Mises support them brand new Kia
proposal no arithmetic I ask you show me
etiquette every day you have more cars
and the roads in the streets and it's
really hard to change the infrastructure
to support that so right now we are
jointly instead in this problem the main
point you are trying to answer here is
how we can predict the traffic condition
in the near future to predict the future
basically you have to know that the best
the traffic prediction project uses data
available by social networks Department
of Transportation and data that a user's
grade themselves while they move around
the city the idea is to combine all that
and to create a solution in real time
helping the users to get from point A to
point B in a more efficient way this
project uses Microsoft Azure as the
platform to enable it as a service
Microsoft Azure helps us a lot in
building the traffic prediction model
because it is a lot of data for instance
the traffic flow from being Maps traffic
incidents informations available through
sensors on the roads social networks for
instance first square Instagram where
people can share their locations all
those kind of informations can be
combined to forecast the traffic jam for
the next 15 minutes 30 minutes one hour
we need to collect data from long
periods of time and process them given
the processing and storage capabilities
of asier this was from the mint overall
project the main series that I applied
the prediction models are New York Los
Angeles London and Chicago the model
presented great results more than 80% of
accuracy using only traffic flow data
and we still are working on the
characterization of other sources such
as traffic incidents and social networks
voice applicatio
o me o es Valencia juice demise Bodie
ellos 'es tense ultra bala cáceres
historico z' da de forma de varias head
so she is in tratamiento cheese Canada
is inform our soils s tornados mice
confusion - Dodds mice very smooth bombs
of Syria who can truly do track the
sedan